and I am excited for the weeks ahead I'm
excited to stand here as Europe hasn't
for Prime Minister because the Liberal
Democrat government will stop bricks it
and build a brighter future
we're being ambitious because we can be
and because we have to be politics is in
a state of flux the full line is no
longer about the left versus right eat
the localities whether we are open or
closed liberal authoritarian we all
don't the only uncertainty is what for
the marriage whether as the two big old
tired party hope that things will go
back to business as usual or whether
mixed physicalness of course seismic
change whether a new and different
politics
millions of voters have actually don't
let anyone tell you what has to happen
change is possible and you get to choose
like the enemies like Madonna like spam
like Sarah like Chuck who chose to join
the Liberal Democrat to leave those
tired all the parties that are stuck in
the past and join us and be part of
creating something new and exciting for
our politics for our country like a
million promoters who trained elect
Liberal Democrat MEP earlier this year
for the first time
seeing the Liberal Democrats beat both
the Conservatives and Lib party in a
national election this is not a normal
election it's not a typical choice about
whether you want the red team or the
blue team to be in government for a few
more years in other times in these
circumstances Liberal Democrats might
have looked to double our see maybe a
bit more
our country needs us to be more
ambitious right now and we are rising to
that challenge because this choice is
about the future of our country for
generations to come
it is not like the red team is losing
because of this issue they merge into
one both labour and the Conservatives
watch negotiate and deliver briggsie and
everybody knows breaks that has taken
longer and cost more than anyone said
that it would but any type of breaks
that will damage our economy will cost
jobs and starve our public services of
the resources that they need Boris
Johnson only cares he is not fit because
he has his interests ahead of the
national it is clear vote for labour is
a vote for breaks it every single time
Jeremy Corbyn refuses to say whether he
would vote to remain or leave it clear
the remains cannot trust Jeremy Corbyn
with their boots I am absolutely certain
I can do a better job
[Applause]